invité de france 24 maintenant nato
part-dieu bonjour merci d'être avec nous
vous êtes cartographe analyste de
l'institut d'études du géo politiques
appliquées qu auteur de l'atlas
géopolitique du monde contemporain on va
essayer de comprendre avec vous ce
terrain justement à quoi ressemble ce
relief sur lequel se déroulent ces
opérations
écoutez on vous rappelle l ukraine et
sur une plaine c'est un endroit où il ya
très peu de relief
c'est également le deuxième pays
européen en termes de superficie
derrière la russie donc si on regarde
une carte de l'ukraine où l'on
s'aperçoit
de cet immense frontière entre l'ukraine
et la russie ou en fait il n'y a aucun
obstacle naturel à part peut-être des
risques et donc d'un point de vue
strictement géographiques
l'ukraine est une cible facile
pour l'armée russe
mais l'armée russe doivent faire face à
un obstacle
auquel elle s'est préparée c'est à dire
les zones urbaines
où ces colonnes de chars qui sont prévus
pour combattre dans les zones de plaine
sont bien moins efficace passe à
redéploiement guérilla urbaine de la
plage
d'omaha seconde question nato tardieu
dans ce type de situation pourrait avoir
tendance à penser que ce sont les
agresser qui ont l'avantagé du terrain
qu'ils connaissent est ce que cela vaut
pour vous et pour les opinions à votre
avis
oui sachant que l'armée russe quand même
connais très bien ce morveux peu de
terrain
après il faut bien imaginer que dans la
mémoire de tous les russes et de l'armée
russe un comparatif pourrait être fait
avec la bataille de grozny en 94 et 95
ou en fait l'armée russe est entré dans
les chars de la principale ville petit
génie alors en rébellion et ses prix de
nombreux revers et et a subi de
nombreuses défaites et pour venir à bout
de cette résidence de cette résistance
pendant tchétchène l'armée russe a
simplement vu rasé grosse bout ce
qu'elle ne veut pas faire pour les
principales villes ukrainiennes merci à
vous les différents merci beaucoup nato
tardieu d'avoir été avec nous sur france
24 cartographe géographe analyste à
l'institut d'études de géo pour
l'éthique appliquée merci